a good chinwag has always been at the  heart of community we here at the gore  District Council recognize that so we're  reviving the art of conversation with  the introduction of a new community  newsletter it's called chinwag from  today Shem wags available online every  second month there's also a limited  number of printed copies at the usual  council facilities as well as Gore  hospital paper plus the warehouse and  clutter box in matara an alternative  months chinwag will appear as page in  the news link community paper one of the  real benefits of shem where because you  can subscribe directly and receive an  email alert every time a new issue was  published by doing verse council can  engage directly with you and to you with  the council so we hope you enjoy our  first chinwag as much as we've enjoyed  putting it together and to be sure to  spread the word you know it's going to  be a good read  you